mon père a rejoint starfleet parce
qu'ils y croyaient
moi sur un défi
tu l'a imité pour voir si tu pouvais
faire aussi bien
tu as passé tout ce temps à essayer
d'être ton père et aujourd'hui tu te
demandes qui tu es vraiment ce n'est pas
si rare vous savez il est facile de se
perdre dans l'immensité de l'espace
il n'ya que vous votre vaisseau votre
équipage
vous tenez vraiment à y retourner
secura sa
on nous attaque
randonnée le vaisseau
c'est pas vrai
je sais pourquoi vous êtes là pourquoi
nous sommes tous là
notre capitaine viendra nous chercher et
il me fera preuve d'aucune pitié
j'espère bien et je la donne
la peur de la mort est il logique
la peur de la mort et ce qui nous
maintient en vie
tous ceux qui vont là bas ils les tuent
mais là ce sont nos amis on va pas les
lâcher comme ça
lyon n'est pas votre force c'est votre
faiblesse
je crois que vous sous-estimez
l'humanité accrochez vous
2 à volonté
noir blanc
vous permettez c'est son fauteuil mada
john stumpf because i bolide
bisphénol
et c'est en terrain connu
utiliser de câble ouest
une vaste surface et youssef monsieur
elco
ats
le jeu
haguenau a évoqué hier wang hao rien
ok merci
chez edf
verdun
fraser
huawei
dr
mais